so
the committee has considered all the
written evidence and the representations
made at the hearing
the committee has also considered the
conditions included within the
application
for a premises license the four
conditions proposed by
environmental health and agreed by the
applicant
and two additional conditions proposed
by the applicant
during the hearing and in order to
promote the licensing objectives
the committee has listened carefully to
the concerns raised by interesting
parties
relating to the proposed hours of nine
pm
nine am to twenty three hundred hours
seven days a week
having the potential to compromise the
quality of life of residents
however the committee was sensitive to
the fact that no representation was made
at the hearing by essex police and by
environmental health
furthermore our environmental health
have agreed conditions with the
applicant that they consider will serve
to promote
the licensing objectives the committee
were also mindful that the applicant
has several years experience of running
similar premises elsewhere
and was committed to working with the
local residents and to provide
a service to them the committee has
resolved to grant the premises license
subject to the usual mandatory
conditions
and the four conditions agreed with our
environmental health
are set out in appendix d the conditions
detailed within the premises license
application form set out in appendix a
and the following two further conditions
offered by the applicant during the
hearing
the opening hours and sale of alcohol on
sundays
to be limited to 9 00 a.m
to 2100 hours
the security door staff to be employed
at the premises on fridays and saturdays
from twenty hundred hours to close
the committee reminds all those present
that the applicant
must adhere to all the conditions
applied to the new premises license
and that if there are any problems in
future as a result of the grant of this
license
a review of the license can be requested
at any time
this concludes the hearing thank you for
attending
thank you chair very much okay
okay good luck